The first images of the newest superhero in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe have hit the
internet — and they look a lot different
than anticipated.
New images from an Atlanta film set show Academy
Award-winning actress Brie Larson actress
fully suited up as Captain Marvel, aka Air
Force pilot Carol Danvers.
Comic book fans will notice a major difference
between Larson's costume here and the way
Captain Marvel is usually depicted in comic
books — namely, it's so green.
As Captain Marvel, Carol's colors have largely
always been red, gold, and blue, with her
Ms. Marvel costume a more revealing black
and yellow.
There is plenty of history in the Captain
Marvel comic books to support the emerald
suit, however — just not with Carol Danvers
wearing it.
Green is the color most typically associated
with Mar-Vell, the original Captain Marvel,
who is set to be played in the upcoming movie
by Jude Law.
Carol received her superpowers due to a disastrous
experience that fused her human DNA with DNA
of the Kree, a spacefaring alien species of
which Mar-Vell is a member.
Could this be an early version of the suit,
obtained shortly after Carol gets her powers?
Or is this her new look for the movie, a tribute
to the hero who came before her?
Either way, it's an awesome look — if a
little bit unexpected.
Captain Marvel is expected to soar into theaters
on March 8, 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!